does your name have to be unique so I
get a lot of questions from
entrepreneurs we're trying to come up
with a name for their business or who
are trying to find their one word and
they wonder does it have to be unique
somebody's already used it how am I
going to send out and be different if
somebody's there to taking that name and
my response is you have to add your own
definition to it you know I believe that
just because somebody else has the same
name or similar name that doesn't mean
that you can't use it and put your own
mark on it and be different with it now
that's not to say you go off and call
yourself Microsoft okay you're going to
get into some legal issues for doing
that but a lot of names have already
been taken right if you're trying to
find your one word I look at mine I
believe you know believe has been used a
million times over right Justin Bieber's
used it movies have been called it songs
have been called it it's been used in
marketing campaigns believe is not a
unique word what's unique is my spin on
it if you're talking about believe and
entrepreneurs I'm the clear leader in
that and how I I definition to it is
believed for me is about believing what
you're doing the passion believing that
it's going to work out and believe in
yourself and those three things are my
unique angle on it and so you know I'm
not that big a believer in that I'm not
that big of a believer I like that I'm
not that big a believing that you need
to have an absolute unique word unique
name just add your own spin on it add
your own definition to it so this
relates to my book because we've
recently found out that there's another
book on the market that has a similar
name to what I want to call my book and
a similar concept not quite exactly the
same but close enough and my publisher
now wants to change the name and you
know part of the reason why I have a
publisher is trust in their expertise
and working with them and that's why
they just didn't do it myself but at the
same time you know I've ordered that
book I've read through it my book is a
hundred times better than in this book
is a hundred pages on you know super
small pages tons of pictures a lot of
worksheets there's very little actual
content in this book and mine is an
insane
piece of art you know the amount of work
and love that's being put into this the
amount of research the amount of
dedication the heart and soul that is
being ripped out of here and put in this
book is incredible and now i'm going to
change my name because somebody else
already has something similar you know
it to me doesn't seem right and I'm
totally confident in my abilities to
out-execute and create something just
way better and so we'll see we'll see
how it goes that's going to be an
interesting couple weeks potential some
fights and i'll keep you guys updated i
want to hit up your questions but first
i want to show up the new shoes these
are the winter version of the vibram
five toe shoes they took an insane
amount of time they get on for the first
time I actually try putting them on last
year and I couldn't get them on and I
and I gave up on into this year I gotta
do it I'm walking the whole foods got to
write my book and so so far so good a
little bit painful a little bit smaller
but I brought the other ones as backup
but it's cold it was snowing last night
so I gotta get ready for some winter
walking all right over to your questions
first up Ben thanks Evan this is such a
great channel I really appreciate all
your hard work and effort that goes in
each of these videos then I appreciate
that really feeling the love there is an
insane amount of work and love that goes
into every video just insane just insane
you know one of the first things I do
every morning is check my youtube
channel and see what's going on both to
see your comments coming in but also see
what new videos are coming up and even
though I have a team I am still heavily
involved in creating every single video
because I want to create something that
that I'm proud of and that I think will
hope and hopefully hope hopefully help
you guys out next up Mohammad how do you
make important choices Mohammad I've
made a couple videos on this in the past
but really big choices you got to make
with the heart not the head too many
people have an approach to write a list
of the pros and the cons and quite often
the thing that makes the most logical
sense to do is the wrong thing for you
to do because the head can only
understand choices that already exists a
world that early exists logic and what
makes sense to do but the heart can
create something new and that's what you
do is entrepreneurs we create something
thing and you want to be able to
recognize a world of possibility rule
that doesn't yet exist when you're going
to go and create and so you make that
decision with your heart not your head
and I think you look at any entrepreneur
who's had success and they've made bets
on themselves when it didn't make any
logical sense and that's how I make
every single big decision in my life
with my heart not my head next up new
future build are not sure exactly how to
switch up my environment as it is now I
want to try putting brighter lights in
my office any better systems organized
around the house to be organized and
more time efficient so last last week I
was talking about how it's important to
have an environment that supports you
that builds you up that allows you to
create amazing things and new future
builder I would say a couple of things
one yes is about your physical
environment yes adding bright lights is
important if you have a window and you
can maximize light coming in that's
great I know in one of my offices I had
to pull out all the lights above me
because they're fluorescent lights and
the flickering just drives me nuts and
had to replace all of that lighting and
so that's definitely one thing but it
also be looking at if you're looking at
a physical environment you know your
office or where you work if it's a home
office or when you go to what's on the
wall when you're there do you have
quotes that inspire you do you have
pictures that mean something to you do
you write down your goals and some in a
place that is visible that in that
motivates you what's the music that you
have on in the background while you work
who are the people who are around you at
that time when you're working what kind
of distractions do you allow into your
life or not what kind of videos do you
consume and blogs and websites do you
read on a regular basis all of this
stuff shapes who you are shapes you're
thinking shapes where you believe that
you can go and if you're not feeding
yourself with high quality information
that makes you believe in yourself and
allows for you to become the best
version of yourself then you're not
going to write so do that with intention
do it on purpose and it also say look at
your routines your habits what are you
do on a daily basis everything that you
do on a daily regular basis
creates the person that you are going to
become and so if you start changing your
habits and your routines and the things
you do regularly you'll start becoming a
new person so that's a secret look at
all those habits and see what you can
change up the two part question still
new future builder Evan can you go
deeper on how you handle not having the
phone in terms of family how do you
handle emergencies get in touch with
people reaching out to others I'm
interested in trying this for one of my
weekly challenges I want to see how it
can work it in with family after they
are used to being able to get ahold of
me at all times so last week again my
video is talking about not dealing with
onion not dealing with interruptions
null team with other people's agendas
for your time and I don't use a phone
right I don't have a cell phone I don't
use an office line I just have a phone
number that goes to voicemail because I
want to be interrupted I don't want
people taking up my time when it's
convenient for them instead of when it's
convenient for me and so you need to
respect your time and how I get by with
family is i use facebook so I facebook
open pretty much all day long and i have
my facebook Messenger app open there and
I guess not an app this is the website
but
my wife is on there my team is on there
my family is on there if somebody needs
to reach me urgently that's a place to
do it and they all know that they know
email I'll get back to you important
people within 24 hours if you need
something urgently then contact me up on
Facebook and it's surprising how few
emergencies there actually are that's
probably the number one complaint or
criticism i get for how do you deal with
emergencies you know a cell phone when
was the last time you actually had a
real emergency what did we do fifteen
years ago when everybody didn't have a
cell phone it's surprising how few
emergencies are actually are and it's
interesting because it teaches the
people around you to solve problems for
themselves without always having to need
you makes people a little bit more self
dependent and suffer lying and then
again when people need to reach me I'm
usually on facebook whenever I'm on my
computer and that's the easiest way to
reach me I did have a cell phone six
years ago when my son was born just
around then because just in case right
just in case you get that phone call
we're going to the hospital and still
never needed it and then after my son
was born I cancel the service so protect
your time value it whether you do use a
cell phone or not just make sure you're
not continually interrupted by others
and again protect your time next up a
new life I want to change my environment
but I can't dude that's a story you're
telling yourself as long as you believe
that then it's never going to happen
your life is not by accident you are at
the moment living other people's
expectations
just break free doesn't mean you have to
move to another country and do something
drastic step by step start making
changes you can control what's in your
room you can control what's in your
office you can control the videos you
watch you can control the people that
you hang out with right it's all in your
control as soon as you abdicate
responsibility as soon as you blame
other people you blame your family
you're being blame your government you
blame everybody else has any done
anything anybody else has done negative
things to you in your life then you'll
never go out and achieve success because
you're living a blame filled life right
I like those sirens timely accept
responsibility everything is under your
control start acting now bro next Shivan
i hope i pronounced that okay hi Evan
it's really fascinated to hear
motivational speeches from you really
enjoy all your videos I appreciate you
from the heart please tell me if I could
do something for you your motivation
works faster than a bullet train god
bless you Evan I love that man thank you
motivation works faster than a bullet
train it's interesting that I've never
seen myself as a motivational speaker
obviously I believe in entrepreneurs and
and I want you guys to be successful and
I guess motivation is a part of that but
I've never considered myself I never
build myself out as a motivational guy
but I appreciate that in terms of what
you can do for me just keep consuming
the content right i mean what i love
seeing is that i'm having an impact
that's what fuels me I love knowing that
the work that I'm putting out is helping
people and so if you like what I'm
creating and it's having a meaningful
impact on your life somehow like the
video share it with your friends even
just leave a comment that stuff fuels me
and makes me want to create more and
when the book is out you can buy some
copies of the book but for now just keep
on sharing man I appreciate it okay last
question a better tomorrow I want to do
a quick shout out to all the awesome
names that we have this week in the
comments we've got new future builder a
new life a better tomorrow I'm loving
the names on the YouTube channel this
week thanks guys so a better tomorrow
asks my struggle is that I have ideas
but i don't know how to start them I
don't know too much about marketing so
i've been reading more about it but i
just can't seem to figure it out by the
way great video Evan so better tomorrow
there is no one key to success apart
from you got to have an idea and start
you don't need to know about marketing
yet you don't need to know about all
these things that you think you need to
know about because there's that some of
the people who are the greatest
marketers in the world and they haven't
started anything people sit on their
ideas you don't do anything with it
because they tell themselves all the
reasons why they can't be successful
right they tell themselves though I
don't know about marketing or I don't
have the money to start this or I don't
have a family that's in business or I
don't know XYZ right fill in the blank
about all the excuses and reasons you're
telling yourself why you can't be
successful we're understand this there
are people who've started massively
successful business who had way less
than what you currently have right now
when they started and the key thing was
for them that they started and they
didn't give up and that's it you have an
idea pick the one that you love the most
the one that you've fallen in love with
the one that makes you come alive the
one you have a deep passion for and
start that and then make sure you work
on it every single day you're working on
getting new clients working on learning
the marketing and you're working on
everything you need to do is to start a
business you're watching these videos
getting tips to grow that's it start
don't make it this big thing don't make
it this insane goal then you built this
huge story up in your head about why
you're never going to be able to do it
or I need a business partner I need an
investor before I get started just start
build momentum start share your idea
provide value you start building a
successful business and when you do link
it up because I want to know and I want
to see it thank you guys another great
video I appreciate the questions let me
know what you think leave a comment if
you have a question about my book your
book the book writing process leave it
in the comments below and I will do my
best to answer it for you next week have
a great day i'm off to start writing
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon